hey guys dr. Berg here I want to answer
a question off my website relating to
the dangers of cardiovascular problems
if you're not sleeping and if you're
exercising okay now the answer to that
question relates to chapter 14 where I
talked about exercising for your body
type okay and there's two things to this
answer number one you know if you ask
anyone is exercise good for the heart
they're going to say oh yes it decreased
risk of heart attacks okay but here's
the thing if you combine high exercise
high intensity exercise or a
long-distance type exercise with
insomnia sleep apnea okay you are going
to dramatically spike your risk for
heart attacks alright why because when
you're tired the body the cardiovascular
system is very very messed up if you
ever looked at a graph of a heart when
you're tired it's it's actually very
very weak okay so sleeping really
improves the cardiovascular function
because the heart has to beat all the
time so it needs to heal when it sleeps
right so if you're not sleeping your
heart is under stress okay now if we add
another layer of exercise on top of that
it's not going to be a pretty picture
your risk for a heart attack will spike
okay
so here's what you need to do use this
principle to adjust your workouts
based on your energy level in your sleep
okay so if you can sleep good and you
have a lot of energy then go for it do a
high exercise intensity type workout but
if you're not sleeping the only exercise
that you should do is either yoga
walking or pilates nothing high
intensity because you're going to put
your heart at risk and I only see these
people trying desperately to lose weight
and they're at the gym at 4 o'clock in
the morning they haven't slept and
they're pushing trying to burn off these
calories and first of all they're not
going to lose weight okay
secondly they're going to create a lot
of chest problems the symptom of heart
problems is tension
on the upper right back on your mid-back
right to the left side or the left
shoulder okay
also having a tired heart will then
prevent you from sleeping so the point
is that you must fix the sleep you know
I have a you can try my adrenal night
formula you can try other sleeping type
remedies but make sure that they don't
have another tonin make sure they're
natural okay use the acupressure on the
adrenals there's many things you can do
to help to sleep but never ever ever do
any type of long-distance exercise or
high-intensity if you have not slept
okay so go ahead and apply that and I
will see you in the next video